foreign
[Music]
everyone welcome to oh I think I went
too far all right welcome to your guide
to tuning Foundation models thank you
for showing up at 8am my name is Nikita
and I'm joined by my teammate yarik and
today we'll be talking a little bit
about how to train Foundation models on
vertex Ai and then Hussein from flybitz
will take the stage to share with you
some practical lessons about tuning
large language models
but before we get into talking about
different methods and ways of tuning I
just want to spend a minute talking
about why we might want to tune a
foundation model on a custom data set in
the first place
so if you've had a chance to experiment
with some of these Foundation models you
might have noticed that one of the
things that makes them so powerful is
that a single model can be used for so
many different tasks
so depending on the way you structure a
prompt you can use an llm for something
like brainstorming if you write a
different prompt you can use that same
model for classification and that same
model for extraction and that same model
for summarization and you get the idea
right depending on how you write a
prompt we can use these models for all
sorts of different tasks
but depending on the task you're trying
to solve coming up with prompts can be
tricky small changes and wording or word
order can impact the model results in
ways that aren't entirely predictable
you can't really fit all that many
examples into your prompt and the more
examples you try and shove into your
prompts the more eats into your input
contacts window it's a very iterative
process and even when you do find a
prompt that works well for your use case
you might notice that the results aren't
entirely consistent
so what I'm saying is that if you spend
enough time trying to experiment and
prompting large language models you kind
of start to realize that a single model
that can do absolutely everything has
some practical limitations
but luckily if we do task specific
tuning we can make these models more
reliable for certain use cases
So today we're going to introduce you to
the two different tuning services on
vertex AI we have supervised fine tuning
which is well suited for tasks where a
human could kind of relatively easily
come up with a standard or correct
answer that could be kind of Justified
or explained but there are some use
cases where it's not so easy to come up
with what the correct answer is you can
think of that as like a chat use case
where maybe if you were given a couple
different examples of answers you'd be
able to pick which one was better but it
would be hard to say exactly what makes
the correct answer correct and for those
types of scenarios reinforcement
learning from Human feedback is really
useful
so I said there were only two services
but actually since you all showed up at
8am today I'm gonna let you in on a
secret we have a distilling step-by-step
and experimental we won't be talking
about it today very much but this is a
tuning technique where you transfer
Knowledge from a larger model to a
smaller model so stay tuned for that
again we'll be focusing on supervised by
tuning and rlhf today but just wanted to
let you know we have this an
experimental and stay tuned for more
information
okay so broadly speaking when it comes
to tuning models we can kind of take two
different approaches so if you're
already familiar with machine learning
if you're familiar with transfer
learning you might know about full fine
tuning and this is where we take a model
that's been pre-trained on some generic
data set we make a copy of that model
and then we retrain the model and we
update all of its many weights but with
these Foundation models they're very
very large probably larger than models
that most of us have been used to
working with in the past and so a full
fine-tuning job requires a very large
training job it's a lot of compute and
then at the end of that you have this
giant model that now you have to serve
um so in a lot of cases this isn't
necessarily the best option and so
alternatively what we can do is
something called adapter tuning where
we're only updating a small subset of
the model weights and not all of the
model weights
so on vertex AI currently for both
supervised fine-tuning and reinforcement
learning from Human feedback we are
releasing adapter tuning which enables
tuning the model to specific tasks
without having to rebuild the entire
Foundation model and this happens via
parameter efficient techniques
so these small subset of parameters
might be a subset of the existing model
parameters or an entirely new set of
model parameters my diagram here is a
little bit simplified but hopefully
conceptually it gives you the idea
what's going on here the exact set of
parameters that are updated depends on
the technique you're using and the kind
of optimal methodology is an air open
area of research it keeps changing but
regardless of which kind of methods you
choose
there are some big benefits to adopter
tuning so the first is that you know you
get faster training because there's
fewer parameters to tune and you also
need less training data than you would
compared to full fine tuning
and then parameter efficient or sorry
doctor tuning also makes serving models
simpler as well because you don't have
to serve the entire base model you just
have to worry about the specific tuned
weights you have and then attaching
those onto your base model and you're
good to go
and the way that this works in vertex AI
is that adapter tuning jobs run on cloud
tpus or gpus via the vertex AI training
service
vertex AI creates a separate tenant
project for each customer project and
the training workloads run on VMS in
that tenant project so the key takeaway
here is that your training data your
input prompts and your tuned weights
never leave your environment and they
are never used to tune the foundation
models so we have a whole white paper
about this if you want to learn more and
learn more about how that works I
encourage you to check that out I've got
a screenshot here it's called adaptation
of large Foundation models
okay so full full fine tuning and
adapter tuning aside let's talk about
the Practical things how do you actually
use these services on vertex Ai and
we're going to start with supervised
fine-tuning
so like I mentioned before this is well
suited to tasks where a human can kind
of come up with a standard or correct
answer that can be justified or
explained relatively easily so you can
think of good use cases as you know you
want to teach the model like specific
structures or formats formats for
generating outputs specific behaviors
like when to respond with a terse output
or maybe being more verbose and the way
you structure your data is in each input
row or record in your data set is your
input prompt followed by the expected
output from the model
so one way I like to think about these
use cases is they're really supervised
fine tuning is well suited for examples
where you want to take data in one
format and convert it into another
format and like while that might sound
very boring there are a lot of different
use cases that kind of fall under this
pattern so something might be taking a
conversation and removing all the pii or
taking some unstructured description
about a clothing item and then
restructuring the key attributes as Json
or taking a user request extracting the
key pieces of information and then
reformatting it in some domain specific
language and all these use cases there
is some notion of like what is the
correct answer and they make for very
good use cases for supervised fine
tuning
and you can kick off with supervised
fine-tuning job from the cloud console
or you can use the vertex AI python SDK
if you like but regardless of what
methods you choose all of the vertex AI
Training Services are built on top of
our existing ml Ops tooling and so this
means that all of your training
workflows are orchestrated as vertex AI
pipelines like this one here so you can
always monitor them in the cloud console
and all of your tuned models will be
available for you in the model registry
so with that I'm going to hand it over
to yarick who's going to talk more about
the rlhf service on vertex
okay
[Applause]
so as Nikita mentioned there is a set of
NLP tasks which can be very well
addressed using techniques described
before so supervised fine tuning
especially tasks where mapping between
output input and output is very well
defined and outputs are unambiguous so
tasks like classification some forms of
extraction and the extraction extractive
q a even some cases of summarization
like extractive summarization when it's
pretty well defined what's very right
answer but there's many other scenarios
where it's difficult to say what's a
good answer let's say a summarization
text may be summarized in many different
ways and each of our ways may be correct
but may be preferred by different people
by different audiences so there is this
kind of loosely defined element of a
preference and a preference for maybe
even a specific audience or a specific
group of people
and the reason behind it is that when we
train pre-train the models and when we
find Universe using supervised fine
tuning the training objectives in a case
of pre-training predicting the next
token or in case of supervised tuning
mapping the input to the output do not
really reflect what we really want to do
which is to train the models which
follow user instructions user intentions
and do it in such a way that they are
helpful they are
harmless and they are honest
those three words are not random but
it's in fact a paper which explains
exactly what we mean here when models
have those characteristics and it's very
difficult to capture those objectives
using the standard objective
functions just when we use pre-training
or supervised fine-tuning scenarios so
there's a lot of techniques this is in
fact a very exploding field of trying to
align the models better with user
intentions user preferences or with some
Universal values which we as Humanity
May value and respect one of those
techniques is RL HF and in my talk I'm
going very briefly describe rlhf
algorithm as this was introduced by open
Ai and as we implemented in our solution
and then we'll go through how to use it
in vertex environment so let's start
with a what is rlh so our lhf technique
was described in pretty good detail in
fact very good detail it's between the
main part of the paper and appendices
close to 70 pages in this paper
published by openai training language
models to follow instructions with human
feedback in this paper they refer to the
technique described in another paper
from 2017 deep reinforcement learning
from Human preferences this is a paper
which was the written jointly by a
deepmind and open Ai and in this paper
we introduced technique of introducing
human feedback into a standard
reinforcement learning Loop in this case
they were training small robots and
trying to build the models which play
Atari games but the bottom line is that
the key innovation in those of the
techniques was incorporation of this of
a human feedback and human intentions
into the training process so let's
quickly go over rlh R lhf usually
comprises three stages you start with a
model you want to fine tune this model
may be a base pre-trained model it may
be the model which was instruction tuned
it may be a model which was even
supervised tune on a specific set of
tasks yes but you start with a model
um and values this model to generate
outputs you have a set of problems and
use this model to generate the outputs
and for the single prompt you know
generate multiple outputs like if you
read the paper open AI generated between
four to nine
responses to a given prompt and by
changing some of the parameters like
nuclear sampling on of those common
parameters you can control when
generating outputs to the prom you will
get different answers another is a key
step in the process those answers are
now rated by humans and the way they are
rated to avoid some issues yes with
absolute scales where human laborers
will compare one answer to the other and
they will specify which they prefer and
this is your data set yes so you create
basically a data set sometimes referred
to as a preference data sets and you
will see the exact form format of his
data set as we require that in our
services but the conceptually the data
set has a prompt it has two answers
possible answers to the prompt and it
has a label which defines which of those
answers was preferred by human labor so
this data set captures preferences of
humans now to be more precise it doesn't
captures preference preferences of all
humans it captures preferences of a
specific labeler or laborers who were
used to create this data set now this
data set is used to create something
called a reward model this is the model
it's effectively a regression model
which takes normally an input sequence
and retains a square scalar value and
this value
the nodes how well the model
preferred an input sentences that's why
it's called a reward model so the higher
the number the better learn the input
sequence or the or response from the
model is aligned with the values and
intentions captured in very World model
now as you can see on this diagram
rlhf and reward model the way I Define
this only one way of incorporating human
feedback into the fine-tuning loop says
there are some other methods there is
something which is pretty hot these days
in research called constitutional Ai and
most vendors apply a few different
techniques which go beyond the
straightforward rhyp in their
implementations with the detail yes
there's a little bit of a magic
happening in those implementations I
cannot talk about yes but there's it's a
very very active area of research and
there is a constant improvements almost
on a daily basis okay so now we have a
very old model so this reward model is
now used in the second stage of training
when we now fine-tune our original model
utilizing this reward signal from a
reward model as part of an objective
function
and the algorithm which was described by
open Ai and which we also use
in our implementations called PPO a
proximal policy optimization so this is
a pretty old well understood very well
performing algorithm from reinforcement
learning and one of the key features of
this algorithm is that in addition to
incorporating reward signal into the
fine tuning process it also make sure so
that you don't overfit the model to the
reward signal so it kind of there is a
penalty component in the objective
functions which makes sure that as you
tune the model it stays relatively close
to the original model while
incorporating those the feedback and
assessment of the responses to the
prompts as defined by the reward model
and why I'm mentioning that as you will
see when we go through our pipelines and
there is a key parameter you have to
configure which controls this panel yes
and controls basically the PPO algorithm
yeah so that's the process again you
start with creating a preference data
set in reality this is probably one of
the most complex part yes how do I find
laborers who can properly create this
data set and if you read the paper it
may be in fact a pretty complicated
process any expensive process to create
this data set when we use this data set
to train the reward model and then we
use very reward model in a reinforcement
learning Loop just to fine-tune our llm
by the way reward models also start as
an alarms in in this context yeah they
are usually a little bit smaller or
maybe a little bit smaller than an LM
where I find tuning openai mentions 6
billion parameters for for the base for
a reward model our reward models are
about the same size yes when you when
you look at implementation but they can
be as big as the model you tune if you
return Tropic papers or some of the
papers from deepmind they used really
large models as reward models models
with 70 billion parameters and so on
yeah so it is still a choice yes of your
implementation and a little bit of
experimentation which is going on in
that space okay so this is the algorithm
how did we oh first of all does it work
no it does work because this is a couple
of charts one chart the chart on a right
side of on my right side of the picture
the diagram is from original open eye
paper which shows you performance
improve movements you can get after
Early Child tuning the model the measure
is Win rate so basically the if somebody
would assess now two answers to the same
prompt one generated by a base and tuned
model and one generated by the model
tuned with r lhf one answer wins yeah so
as you can see the win rate for those
rlhive tune models increases
dramatically over
non-tuned models and in fact in the
paper the quad with the small rlh tune
model
1.3 billion parameters perform better on
the stairs than a 475 billion gpt3 model
so there's definitely Improvement in
some cases now not everything is perfect
because there are also some side effects
of rlhift tunings I don't have time to
talk about it but there's always a
little bit of a win-lose situation as
when you when you perform both tunings
and there's a chart the upper chart are
some of our experiments with different
models so as you can see we see very
similar proportionately very similar
improvements in the performance of the
models for different types of models yes
different sizes of T5 models and our
text bison model which is kind of a
flagship model in our API
okay so how is it implemented similarly
to the supervised fine-tuning
service it is implemented as a Vertex
pipeline now you see the vertex Pipeline
on a chart it's relatively complicated
so I'm going to drill down to specific
parts of a pipeline in the following
slides but this is the pipeline which
implements the full rrhf workflow as I
described a few minutes ago
and how do you access it again yes it's
a pipeline which by the way we open
sourced as of this week you can look at
this pipeline not kubeflow pipelines
GitHub repo here we have implementation
of this Pipeline and we also included
this pipeline in a Google Cloud
components SDK
so you can create the pipeline by
importing rlhs pipeline from from this
package and then following the standard
process with coupon pipelines you
compile the pipeline into the
intermediate representations which will
be then processed by vertex pipelines
and you submit a pipeline job and the
pipeline job will have a set of
parameters there is quite a few of them
I only listed a few examples first of
all obviously you specify location of
your data sets there are parameters
which control how many steps you will
execute for tuning for creating training
very word model for tuning your base
model and there you go the last
parameter is this coefficient KL
coefficient this is the coefficient
which controls the span out here which
controls how far the tuned model will
deviate from the base model yes and you
know the lower the value
of the lower the penalty if you set the
value to zero it will not
it will not force any kind of alignment
with the base model
okay so let's drill down to a few
aspects of this pipeline these are the
formats of a data set for the preference
data set as I described both data sets
by the way are Json L files the
preference data set will have a field
called input text this is your prompt it
will have two
possible outputs so possible Generations
from the model for office prompt
candidate 0 candidate one and it has a
field Choice which specifies user
preference in this case but candidate 0
was preferred by the human laborer the
second data set this is the data set
which is used in our reinforcement
learning Loop to tune the model from
data set is very simple it's basically a
set of prompts now it is important that
both
prompts in the preference data sets and
in your prompt data sets they should
come from the same distributions but
they should not be the same because you
know it's standard machine learning yes
you don't you want to avoid Target
leaking and all those other effects and
you have to make sure that they are
sampled for the same distribution so you
have a meaningful training workflow
now when you drill down to the pipeline
this is kind of the tuning the training
part of the pipeline so the key steps is
this reward model trainer this is the
step which encapsulates the code which
trains very old model and then the
reinforcers step this is the
reinforcement learning step which fine
tunes the base model there is a bunch of
helper components this result machine
spec component is kind of important
similarly to supervised fine-tuning we
can tune the models using gpus or using
tpus and it kind of depends on a region
in which you want to tune so if you want
to tune on gpus we will use eight a100
gpus model with 80 gigabytes of device
memory and if you tune on tpus we'll use
32 slice dpov3 yes of a TPL slice V3 TPU
slides with 32 cores this is the minimum
requirement to run by pipeline
so after the model is tuned the models
are stored
in Google Cloud Storage in your Thailand
projects and then there is a subgraph
which deploys the model to vertex
prediction and so this is a standard
deployment process we register the model
in the vertex model registry and then we
deploy the model to vertex online
prediction endpoint and at the end here
you will have a model deployed to vertex
prediction and you can now use Bethune
model exactly the same way you would use
any other model in vertex using exactly
the same API where you would use to
access models like text bison or version
average generative AI models which are
exposed no difference nothing specific
to that and there is another part of a
pipeline patch in France so so what this
step in the pipeline does we if you
provided a test data set we will run the
batch influence of this test data set
and generate responses so you can later
use some form of evaluation if you want
to compare those responses to other
models we do have other pipelines
evaluation pipelines which can help you
with this task if you want to do the win
rate analysis if you want to use again
humans to validate your responses or if
you want to use some kind of automatic
evaluations like when snx pipeline which
is covered in some other talks which
uses an oracle model to make those
decisions so the bottom line is a pretty
comprehensive easy very easy to use
pipeline which implements quite complex
workflow and quite complex algorithms
and that's it for my part of a
presentation and now I will invite
Hussein to the podium to talk about
really interesting stuff yes how it is
all applied in practice
[Applause]
about nine years ago I had a similar but
disappointing experience as a graduate
student I hosted the workshop at 8am at
an academic conference about contextual
fine tuning of models and almost no one
showed up
uh but look at you you know it's great
to have you here at 8 A.M so maybe a big
round of applause for you the audience
for showing up at 8am
[Applause]
my name is Hussein random I'm founder
and CEO of flybitz headquartered in
Toronto I'm also a professor at MIT
media lab in Cambridge and representing
the work of my team today that they are
working on some unique capabilities
allowing large language models to be
used in very specific granular privacy
preserved settings when you don't want
your data to to leave your premises and
you want to contain their integrity and
and privacy
so um
let me just go to this one language
models are great we can do so many cool
things with them from answering
questions through translating to
reasoning to code completion and you're
just getting better and better and
better as we are having more parameters
in these models
but we may agree that they lack a few
things
it's sometimes difficult to apply them
in a very specific domain the more
specific they become you require more
tuning capabilities
and also they lack context right
um
the big thing is do you understand the
intent of those prompts and questions
why are you asking that question who are
you asking that question as are you a
student are you a an engineer what is
your intent so those are some of the
things that our team members are working
on to figure out if we can capture
intent when you are creating these
prompts and also they are not very good
with multi-hub reasoning like when you
have sequences of logic that will need
to come together and infer language
models are not good with those
few examples fly bits does a lot of work
in the financial space you know for
those of you familiar you know banks
have a lot of data distributed and siled
in multiple repositories they have
different semantics different ontologies
so if you have a pre-trained language
model and someone wants to understand
the relationship of home financing
versus the risk guidelines just imagine
the types of graphs and nodes you need
to put together to really personalize
that answer
the moment yes we can use very
fine-tuned language models but they are
not very scalable and they're very
expensive to maintain and and scale
think about other examples like two
individuals one is student one a
neurologist not that neurologists make a
lot of money but my team came up with
this example are more or less asking a
question about a trip to Greece but
think about the context of that question
what one may have budgetary confinements
the other one is actually looking for a
plan so although the prompt and the the
question is the same there's a lot of
context in that question that you need
to address and how do you really bring
that embedded personalization into these
prompts so that's another thing that our
team is is working on
and you know most of you are familiar
with this language models are very bad
when it comes to multi-hub reasoning
right the classic example in the
literature a farmer has a certain number
of chickens and rabbits on this Farm the
total number of heads is 20 and the
total number of Lex is 58 how many
chickens and how many rabbits does the
farmer have
you are super smart people you can
answer that question relatively quickly
language models can't the reason is well
there are lots of unknowns
um they need to formulate the context
they really need to figure out the
equations and then they need to explain
the output so explainability and audit
also becomes an issue and there's a lot
of literature these days about how they
are addressing these issues
so uh our team is working very closely
with Google these are you know summaries
of how we are using tuning most of
you're familiar with this usually I can
divide divide them into two key areas
one is in context learning in which the
commonality in them is that you really
keep your model Frozen you don't touch
your
um you know language model and then in
some cases you may provide some examples
and you may get an array as an output
that's the first one sometimes if you
need a vector as an output in embeddings
you can still keep your model Frozen get
an embedding and use it for retraining
or or training it with other models this
is usually useful when you know token
sizes are important for you you have you
know confined questions and answers and
that's usually how you use one of these
techniques and Google as the Eric
mentioned they have some very good
models with with text bison and text
embedding with that the other approach
is when you have a lot of data and
usually that later data is labeled token
size is no longer that much of an issue
so you actually make your model tunable
I so it's not frozen anymore it can
become sentient and it can change and it
can become dynamic doesn't mean any of
anyone is better than the other one but
usually you can address some of the
requirements in terms of which one to
use based on which context so one of the
core examples I share with you we do a
lot of work in the financial space a lot
of credit card companies so we have the
ontology and the semantics of the credit
card business
our prompt Engineers provide about 20
examples more or less for a particular
workflow we fine-tune the the dlm and
then the expectation is that a new
request will generate a new response in
form of natural language or even if you
want in form of a script so this is an
example if you just let me tell you a
little bit about what what flybits does
we are very good in generating
contextual experiences for our customers
in the old days we also had a think
about a visual Journey Builder put the
structure in place put the entities in
place build their workflows now a lot of
that is getting replaced by by language
models so instead of expecting a
marketer or a designer to go and build
this from scratch they can just type or
they can just talk even using audio and
then the experience will be created for
them so in this case
The Prompt is you know someone's is I
want to create an experience that can
reduce fraud I want to make sure that I
Target transactions more than a
particular dollar value and then you
have elements mapped that understand the
request type request objective request
Rule and then the action so just by
about 20 examples you will be able to
generate a script and then that script
can be used for you know any type of
workflow that that you want this is a
classic example that we use some of
these language models so the pros and
cons you know they're relatively easy to
use they're becoming easier and easier
and easier they have data efficiency
they have versatility and they have fast
training but what are the negatives
very very prone to biases right you need
to really find a balance between how
generalized or how fine-tuned you want
the model to be if you generalize too
much you may have ambiguity if you
really fine tune it then you really may
miss that generalization capability so
those are all the things that you know
you can address in your
prompt engineering exercises
uh the other thing that I would like to
show you is a capability we created
called Nestor anyone here familiar with
the Tintin comics the comic book
it was more popular in Europe there was
a character in that book called Nestor
who was the concierge for Captain
haddock and but he was very good at it
was that before the captain asked for
something he was he had it ready and he
he delivered it so that's why we called
this uh Nester and the premises of that
are two things one is to
I really use a neurosymbolic approaches
to reason using graphs so the the idea
is the input comes in as natural
language we have a fine-tuned palm model
and then using reasoners and using
symbolic representations we have the
ability to go and consult a large data
sets that are being formed in form of
graphs and then you can query the graph
return it as a symbolic representation
or script and then you can translate
that into
into a natural language again so the
example of that is
a marketer an experienced designer comes
on an interface and say I would like to
build an experience that provides 15
bonus to my loyalty program providers in
Canada right that's that's cool you know
that that I will benefit from that so
what then happens is that you will use
your tune model you will create a
symbolic representation you reason
through querying your knowledge graphs
but the problem with this example if you
consult your location model is that you
have a lot of ambiguity that the tune
model understand so it comes back again
with a prompt asking for more
information
tell it asks the user tell a little bit
more about who do you need to address in
Canada people in Canada outside Canada
people who travel and just going through
that elicitation and feedback you will
get
responses that are more personalized and
more relevant to uh to what you want to
do
the last thing I want to highlight which
is a big strategy for us is you know
prompt engineering is is amazing it's
becoming more and more advanced but
wouldn't it be great if you can have
recommendation on auto prompts what are
the good questions you can ask from your
data that's where we spend a lot of our
time you know it's what is the right
question to ask and that also goes back
to uh to to some good philosophy so our
researchers working on knowledge graphs
to really combine
um semantic networks and semantic graphs
with AI models graph and combine it so
that we can actually you get reasonable
or Reason ready graphs for for querying
so the the process without going through
the details is you have these think
about a knowledge graph that represents
I don't know some sort of an ontology
Banks or Healthcare or even more
granular like credit cards or or loyalty
you use some sort of a pre-trained graph
neural network to really understand it a
little bit better and add to it if it
can then you also have an AI model model
graph an AI model graph you know the
your your semantic graph could be just
nodes and relationships your AI model
graph can also have weights and and and
relationship and function so for example
you may have a model graph that has a
Bayesian node for calculating risk and
it may have a causal inference node and
it may have a fuzzy logic node and then
it really understand in what situation
in which context which node to use for
that type of inference when you bring
these two together kind of the semantic
graph that you have and the AI graph
then you're going to have a reason ready
graph that is going to be very powerful
when you uh when you query it so first
step is have an AI model graph the
number of them available your data
scientists can build some then you use a
pre-trained GNN against your ontologies
and semantics you basically combine them
in some sort of unified graph and you
make your graph reason ready
so that's becoming this is one of the
approaches that we are using uh for
generating Auto prompts that's a very
interesting field for us like tell me
about your data tell me about your graph
but also tell me what are the 10 best
questions that I can ask from it and if
you wear a contextual lens on it as well
that becomes more interested I am
interested to ask questions about my
data in a risk situation I'm interested
to ask questions about this data when I
want to cross-sell an upsell to my
customers in this location so now you're
getting to a model that of course you
will need prompt Engineers but you can
really accelerate your workflow when
you're building such systems so to
summarize
um I can really categorize it as first
and foremost there is a human element
here it was great to hear from our
colleagues that you know there are
human-centered approaches for this and I
would say at least our experience is
that your even your your fine-tuning
teams your your ml teams are very
interdisciplinary if you just have a
team that are all AI scientists you
really miss the context of the types of
knowledge graphs that you got to create
and the context so go back to the old
saying that build teams that you can
feed them with a large pizza you know
and really you know have complementary
skill sets especially for those
questions and knowledge graphs to be
created uh effectively
um I think where where things are going
is that it will be a fascinating field
to see how llms are becoming more
personalized like really understand
intent and also understand who's asking
and why they are asking I think uh
disability of building reasoners to
translate between objects and scripts
and natural language and learn from that
is also becoming a Super interesting
area
and
um yeah just you know just we all know
llms are great they continue to get
better there's one thing to keep adding
parameters but there's also another
thing to build ecologies and ecosystems
around your models so you can really
contextualize and essentially build a an
inference router that you may have tons
of models and it can know how to combine
them and if you come and if you have a
user interface allowing you to do that
effectively uh I think that will be
great and the last thing I say is that
we are all fascinated by AI but I think
your data strategy is also super
important I I was impressed yesterday
during the keynote to hear about I think
they were called extensions that you can
keep your data in your premises not
moving it into a centralized repository
I mean you used to have T's trusted
execution environments and all that I
think these are advancements of that
that you can now have a price privacy
preserved local environment to benefit
from L Adams but then the concerns of
legal and data portability data
tokenization will become much much
easier to address so if that strategy
which is data decentralization
explainability auditability portability
goes hand in hand with some of the
things that you know I shared with you
that our team are working on I think you
will really find scalable Frameworks for
uh for AI strategies
um I think that's all I had to share
with you and with that I'll pass it back
to Nikita and yeah happy to take you
away thank you
[Applause]